este domingo los guatemaltecos asisten a
las urnas para elegir presidente
vicepresidente congresistas y
autoridades locales se trata de una
convocatoria turbulenta debido a las
decisiones de las autoridades
electorales que negaron las
inscripciones de algunos candidatos
revirtieron otras inscritas y aceptaron
algunas aspiraciones de personas que no
cumplían con los requisitos legales de
la Constitución de ese país para
analizar lo que está en juego en estos
comicios conectamos con Tiziano breda él
es investigador para el Instituto afari
internacional y Bienvenido a France 24
Qué está pasando con las autoridades
electorales de Guatemala Cómo se explica
que se hayan presentado tantas
irregularidades desde la inscripción de
Los candidatos de hecho la aspiración de
Carlos Pineda que fue favorito en
intención de Voto fue anulada
por supuesto Buenos días Valentina
gracias por la invitación efectivamente
el proceso electoral en Guatemala es
extremadamente viciado por estas
decisiones justamente mencionadas y
básicamente no ha de sorprender Pero
porque es completamente coherente con un
camino que se ha dado en los últimos
años en la política guatemalteca en
donde las élites política militares y
económicas del país ha intentado
recomponer un círculo de impunidad un
pacto de impunidad Por así decirlo que
había sido quebrantado en la década
anterior por las investigaciones de una
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad y algunos juicios que habían
expuesto no redes de corrupción y de
violencia en estos círculos más alto
estas esferas más altas de la sociedad
guatemalteca esta elección es
fundamental para finalizar este o por
para mantener esa recomposición del
pacto de impunidad y por lo tanto los
candidatos que más representaban una
amenaza para para este estatus han sido
inhabilitados para esta lección Bueno
hablamos ahora de Los favoritos porque
según las encuestas pues es toda la
presidencia son Sandra Torres y su
fórmula vicepresidencial que es Romeo
guerra un pastor evangélico y ya
empiezan los cuestionamientos porque la
Constitución prohíbe a los candidatos
que sean miembros de una institución
religiosa
precisamente bueno Rome guerra ha
afirmado que había dejado su actividades
como pastor hace hace unos meses antes
de su inscripción pero claramente esto
es cuestionable es precisamente la
aplicación selectiva de algunos
criterios de ley que no solamente
concierne el ámbito electoral sino
también y lo hemos visto en el ámbito de
la lucha contra la corrupción donde se
han aplicado una serie de de conceptos y
de leyes en contra de aquellos que en
realidad han luchado contra la
corrupción y la impunidad Fiscales
jueces y miembros de la sociedad civil
en los últimos años y por el otro lado
no se ha aplicado a casos o indicios de
casos de posible corrupción en el actual
gobierno y y en otras esferas de las
instituciones Así que precisamente hace
parte de este de este de este mismo
juegos o dinámica que
considera también
la candidatura de Sandra Torres que es
una figura controversial es ya la
tercera vez que se presenta a esta
elección y que normalmente es la
candidata fácil de vencerlo si es
percibida porque llega a menudo con
buena prestación con buenos resultados
en primera vuelta pero nunca ganando la
mayoría y luego termina siendo
ganada en segunda vuelta porque es una
figura que genera mucho anticuerpos
sobre todo en las ciudades guatemaltecas
también tenemos a sur y ríos que es hija
de José Efraín Ríos presidente de facto
dictador entre 1982 y el 83 la
Constitución prohíbe que opten al cargo
tanto Los líderes de facto como sus
familiares hasta cuarto grado de
consanguinidad ella es hija que se puede
decir al respecto
efectivamente haya sido excluida de
otras contiendas y en este caso pues ha
sido revertido el juicio de
inhabilitación
para para sobrevivíos sobre Dios de las
candidatas preferida indudablemente por
esas élites a la que me refería a nivel
económico político y militar del país y
es una figura que pero podría resultar
una mala apuesta o tener algunos efectos
Boomerang en esta en este esfuerzo de
estos círculos de promover su
candidatura
inhabilitando otras porque su figura
precisamente
evoca los sentimientos encontrados en la
en la sociedad guatemalteca
particularmente en esa gran mayoría de
población que vive en las áreas Rurales
que ha vivido conflicto armado y esto
efectivamente se está traduciendo en una
muy pobre performance en las encuestas
vamos a ver cómo termina siendo el voto
del domingo pero en la última encuesta
que ha sacado Prensa libre pues ella
quedaría en el tercer lugar hasta el
momento Bueno también tenemos
tanto tiempo para extendernos hablando
de esto y algo que quiero preguntarles
que todos los candidatos estos favoritos
de alguna manera en algún momento han
[Música]
mostrado su acuerdo con las políticas de
nayib bukele en El Salvador y cómo
podrían apropiarse de este tipo de
medidas para mejorar la inseguridad que
está en este momento azotando a
Guatemala qué se puede decir entonces de
esto
seguramente la figura de bukele es y sus
políticas de seguridad tienen una fuerte
componente de político electoral no
solamente en Guatemala sino que en toda
la región latinoamericana porque son muy
populares Aparentemente
eficaces también por lo tanto
digamos proponerlas o proponer emularlas
puede ser considerada una una táctica
electoral ahora bien Yo creo que sea
difícil por una serie de razones que
esto luego se traduzca en una
implementación
parecida no a esta casas a las brujas
que en El Salvador ha llevado la
detención de 70.000 personas pero
indudablemente pues esta propuesta de
una de un estado fuerte de medidas
drásticas en el ámbito de la seguridad
es algo que pues tiene algún tipo de de
aceptación a nivel popular Claro que sí
todos los candidatos lo Proponen pues
dejan de ser básicamente deja de hacer
la diferencia no y brevemente le
pregunto Cuál es además de la
inseguridad serán los principales retos
para el nuevo mandatario
bueno en Guatemala se ha empeorado muy
personalmente la la situación de
desnutrición y de pobreza sobre todo en
las áreas Rurales ya más de 60% de la
población vive por debajo del umbral de
la pobreza el tema migratorio sigue
siendo por lo tanto
una un crítico no para un tema crítico
para para el país la economía ha estado
a flote pero no ha estado creando esas
oportunidades para los millones de
guatemaltecos sobre todo en los demás
departamentos más pobres para quedarse
no y construir un futuro un futuro en el
país y así la pandemia también ha
demostrado la la debilidad en el sistema
de Educación y en el sistema de salud
del país entonces todo eso se áreas creo
que serán
críticas para cualquier candidato para
cualquier nuevo presidente de
digamos llevar a cabo algunas acciones
de tener algunos resultados y muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en France 24
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes por la
invitación feliz día a ustedes también
Muchas gracias por su sintonía vamos a
hacer una breve pausa pero ya regresamos
[Música]